the Columbia University Alumni medal for
distinguished service is presented to
Sarah
Sally Shipley stone 1969 School of
Nursing we were 20 when we came you know
two years of college and we were exposed
to birth death chronic illness acute
illness poverty you know we were
expected to learn rapidly to deal with
these things a woman who was the
president of this student body there was
a quotation by her in the yearbook she
said if you don't like something don't
stand there and complain about it just
go and do something about it that's
always stayed with me too and that came
from so it came from here came from
Columbia came from the late sixties I
was on the search committee for the new
dean this year which was a huge honor
wonderful experience I was able to sort
of some works that I do with the
foundation arranged to have some money
donated to the School of Nursing to
develop a professorship and healthcare
for the underserved the person who who
sit sit in that chair I've become very
fond of she's an amazing nurse
researcher and share so many of the
interests that I do the president of the
University will present the 2010 alumni
medal is a great honor was exciting even
sitting there in the rain these awards
and medals at a private luncheon but now
they do it at commencement it gives a
message to the students that yes as an
alum you can really be involved so I
think it's a gift it gives you a window
into what's happening in your profession
in your school now
and I think it's fabulous